nous sommes le 20 octobre 2001 il est
20h50 tf1 vient de lancer son tout
nouveau télé crochet musical star
academy présentée par nikos aliagas
bonsoir
une quinzaine de candidats vont relever
le défi de vivre durant près de trois
mois sept jours sur sept 24 heures sur
24 sous l'oeil aguerri des caméras
coachée par les meilleurs professeurs
détends-toi
éviction est un phénomène national tous
les samedis soirs ils sont un moyen de 7
millions à regarder le programme qui
réunit sur un même plateau les plus
grandes stars du moment la finale de la
saison - réunira même 15 millions huit
cent soixante douze mille
téléspectateurs devant la victoire de
jenifer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
131 prime 700 quotidienne durant huit
saisons la machine star academy tourne à
plein régime et va révéler au grand jour
de nombreux talents
l'émission sur tf1 s'arrêtera en 2008 à
l'occasion des 20 ans de star academy
alexia laroche joubert et d'anciens
candidats reviennent avec nous ce soir
sur l'émission qui a marqué toute une
génération
[Applaudissements]
merci mario merci d'être là à tous les
trois ça me fait très plaisir de vous
voir ça reste des bons souvenirs ah non
non c'est plus que ça déjà ça a été
quasiment une vie pour moi j'ai fait
l'émission talent ce qui fait faire je
pense que c'est c'la ouais parce que
c'est des moyens incroyable est ce que
c'est une grande grande émission de
variétés parce que c'est des rencontres
avec des artistes français et
internationaux enfin qui a eu la chance
de croiser des charms voilà et mariah
carey
c'est vrai que j'ai bien que tu dises
qui avait beyoncé madonna mariah carey
le casting de fou les plus grandes stars
étaient dans la farine au début elle
voulait pas venir paris a nommé au début
on s'est planté concept voilà clairement
et d'ailleurs ça a été un échec au début
bien sûr n'oublie mais les trois
premières semaines d'audience était très
mauvaise et en fait tout parce que y est
c'est un peu à cause de nous deux on
sortait du loft et en l'occurrence moi
j'étais encore dans l'esprit du loft et
on n'avait pas on n'avait pas compris
qu'en fait compte que les gens voulaient
c'était une grande émission musicale et
quand on a compris sort c'est au bout de
trois semaines on a d'un seul coup
invité des artistes et c'est devenu ce
qu'est la face que maintenant parce
qu'elle était la star ac' grandes
émissions de variétés justement y ait
plein de stars un dedans regarder on
vous a fait une petite compil des plus
grandes stars de la star ac
je dois main son destin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
disant que c'est là
[Musique]
il rate en afrique et la première
c'était le 20 octobre 2001 on a une
première une vidéo du premier prime de
la star ac c'est vrai que au départ on
se disait est ce que ça va marcher c'est
un gros pari qu'a effet tf1 comment au
tf 1 a signé la star ac c'est à cause
d'une offre son état il nous faut un
truc audrey en fait quand je pense
qu'ils étaient frustrés veut pas voir
signer l'offre directement et là en
l'occurrence les deux patrons l'époque
salaires stéphane courbit et arthur sont
vus avec un monsieur qui s'appelle john
de mol qu'était parce que c'est issu
d'un format hollandais alors il que
j'étais dans mon coeur
et donc ils sont venus et ils ont dit
voilà nombre il faut faire un programme
qui soit plus grand public et je pense
qu'ils ont eu raison au final ne pas
signer la story est évidemment de signer
la star ac il leur fallait un programme
qui réunissent les fédérateurs
opérateurs alors regardé le premier
prime de la star ac' regard bonsoir
soyez le bienvenu en direct sur tf1 nous
sommes le samedi 20 octobre il est
exactement 21 53 vous avez entendu
parler ces derniers temps de star
académie aujourd'hui c'est le grand soir
bienvenue soyez les bienvenus à star
académie que va-t-il se passer
mais bon
la nasse non mais si alors qui a choisi
nikos qu'a eu cette fabuleuse idée nikos
et j'ai entendu ce que disait benjamin
sur flavie est en effet c'est vrai que
c'était vrai mais qui était présente
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des discussions
la réalité c'est qu'ils sont ils sont
arrivés avec lui et je me rappelle c'est
tf1 qui nous appelle ils nous disent
nikos et ont dit qu'ils causent et là
ils nous disent bas il était avec
christine bravo etc on regarde on trouve
qu'il a beaucoup de charme qui l'a de
l'aisance et c'est avec la pad métier et
on peut quand il démarre il démarre et
il a été très courageux aussi des alors
lui il n'avait pas de carrière à risque
il avait qu'une chose à gagner énorme
ans il a été courageux et au début il
perd des savoirs et la seule coincé
entre non mais il s'est entraîné s'est
entraîné s'est améliorée avec nous il a
grandi parce que nous aussi on n'était
pas très bons débuts quoi oui
on n'a rien à perdre
allez lâchez vous alors c'est vrai il ya
beaucoup de durs bien aussi qu'il ya eu
le rugby en face de la star academy et
c'est peut-être ça aussi qui a fait que
la star academy à décoller parce que
c'est vrai que voilà sûr c'est france 2
qui vous a fait aussi un beau cadeau il
ya beaucoup de gens qui disent ça aussi
que ça des contrats ça ça il faut rendre
hommage à à patrick le lay enfin côté le
patron stephen moyer pardon excusez moi
qui étais grand patron de tf1 avec
etienne mougeotte et on est dans le
bureau avec etienne mougeotte en
l'occurrence nous on est très embêté des
chiffres de la star academy on est
limité à rendre un peu d'argent suite
alain succès la star ac du lancement et
les producteurs étaient préfère ça ouais
et donc batterie
de il nous dit deux choses il nous dit
bah ça chante pas cependant il avait
raison il nous dit vous avez le goût de
be mathématiquement vous allez gagner
des points de la part d'audience donc un
nombre de téléspectateurs et là vous
allez démarrer mais c'est vrai alors
c'est vrai qu'après les audiences ont
été agréables wii mario voulait dire un
truc non jeu 12 millions de
téléspectateurs avec une pointe à gaza
son nom et avec hugues aufray
web au fric on va recevoir
fait penser à ça alors le candidat
emblématique de la star ac c'est grégory
lemarchal il souffrait de la
mucoviscidose l'a pas empêché d'avoir un
parcours incroyable une fois incroyable
il a fait des duos exceptionnels
dans la star academy 6 plus grands
candidats la star ac
déjà je peux pas dire ça dans bien des
cas lui aussi
en mémoire
l'histoire de grégory c'est qu'ils
n'auraient jamais dû être là voilà et
c'est ça qui est incroyable et c'est ça
qui m'émeut moi quand j'entends parler
de lui je reçois un truc et on me dit
voilà il a vu que v6 doses je l'envoie
pascal [ __ ] ce que je trouve que le
gamin est génial il a une voix génial
mais c'est pas mon métier quand même et
je l'envoie pascal [ __ ] et ils
m'appellent dit tu te rends compte de ce
que tu as fait et je me dis vas mongole
et en faisant ce gamin mucoviscidose tu
fais d'exploitation du malheur des gens
etc il me dit c'est la première fois que
j'entends autant d'actes docteur que
balavoine est donc là je me dis [ __ ]
et voilà et l'histoire a commencé comme
ça et on a été d'ailleurs très discret
on lui a dit on n'en parlera pas de ta
maladie on en a d'ailleurs on en a
jamais parlé lors des prime et c'est une
prouesse parce que on le sait peut-être
pas mais deux jours avant la finale il
était vraiment très fatigué et il a
puisé au fond de lui pour assumer la
finale c'est les médias quand on parlait
sur les eaux de la lys de toujours aller
de l'avant ne jamais baisser les bras de
croire en soi g
[Musique]
toulouse
la star academy 4 été
remportée par
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'à ce soir
[Musique]
on m'a gagné en valeur vous avez gagné
magali la sla 5/5 05 c'est ça c'est vrai
alors n'étiez pas du tout favori tabac à
non moi c'est ça
que vous disiez à chaque fois il ya une
rumeur c'est vrai que les gens avaient
complètement adhéré avec vous et c'est
vrai qu'il paraît que tf1 voilà voulais
que ce soit peut-être quelqu'un d'autre
qui gagne est ce que céderons pas à
l'intérieur je peux pas le dire ouais
bah j'ai vécu là bien sûr comme tous les
autres en sortant quand j'ai vu
certaines images ça je me suis dit
pendant une semaine on m'a pas vu je
sais que la semaine de stone on m'a pas
du tout vu et même mes parents s'y est
ce qu'elle est toujours au château
mais j'ai envie de dire maintenant
m'en fiche ça change et ça je pense que
le public a été là bien sûr le public
était là m'a soutenu et c'est grâce à
lui c'est la plus belle des victoires ça
a changé toute votre vie ah oui on fait
quoi maintenant long mais toujours
jai-chul toujours je suis toujours
chanté sa verge et un single qui arrive
bientôt ça s'appelle comment ah je peux
pas le dire ce sera une surprise non
pour moi si ça sera maman cadeaux mon
cadeau à toutes les personnes qui me
soutiennent depuis 16 ans d'accord et
pour fêter ses 20 ans vous êtes heureuse
ah oui c'est vrai ça c'est une aventure
est incroyable ça a changé ma vie semée
et ça a fait celle que je suis
aujourd'hui alors avec les bons et les
mauvais moments et ça m'a construit et
je suis très très très fier d'avoir fait
cette émission est de l'avoir emporté
bien sûr c'est fou d'avoir remporté cinq
robes c'est quoi c'était 100 mille euros
1,1 million un million un million
d'euros va bien
koh lanta c'est cent mille euros et la
caisse
dis-moi koh lanta ça veut dire tu veux
c'est un truc de ouf tan tan à ce total
quarante jours que l'on passe à la star
ac on n'a pas de fin voilà quand même
barré mais mais franche c'est un million
d'euros pour le gagnons pas mais je peux
parler pour les deux précédents alors
nous justement cent mille c'est parce
qu'on ne veut pas enfin il ne participe
pas vraiment une belle somme c'est une
belle somme monsieur sisi pas pour
l'argent et 1,1 million il faut être il
faut être juste c'est un milieu qui est
un minimum garanti c'est à dire c'est
une avance sur les futures ventes c'est
ça on a 2 millions quoi qu'il arrive
armelle mais nous apprécions d'exploser
on a le million quoi c'est sûr que tu
vois rien je le garderai ça exactement
rien tu gardes c'est bon dis moi je
bénis ça
tu es marié doit
[Rires]
à l'autre finaliste huawei finalistes
saga des millions de quoi y'a rien pour
lui des gens non je te crois pas aux
jeunes quand il repart avec zéro parce
que j avais elodie il y avait et elodie
frégé qui arrive ennemi n'en ont pas et
qui avait partagé
celui-là il a volé l'orangé
et toi le finaliste rien mais on s'est
bien amusé mais toi tu as l'air très
très fier ton aventure aussi je sèche
alors tu viens tu es comme un fou alors
j'ai eu ce matin nikos qui d'ailleurs
vous embrasse nasreen non c'est vrai
c'est vrai ce que je vais le voir tout à
l'heure et voyez ni coup sûr c'est le
nom je devais le voir tout à l'heure
donc on s'appelle de temps en temps
c'est par moi ça reste le grand frère ça
reste pour moi aujourd'hui un exemple
pour le métier en fin de celui que je
connais extraordinaire extraordinaire
l'humilité est une réussite et il est
toujours là après 20 ans qui n'auraient
c'est vrai qu'on n'y croyait pas en plus
ça maintenant elle aussi fait qu'il y
ait ça a été tu as eu des tas fait des
belles rencontres très belle rencontre
mais puis puis moi j'ai eu la chance
aussi j'ai peut-être pas eu le million
mais pendant dix ans j'ai vécu des
musiques assez ça si ça te les deux amis
la lumière musique j'ai eu la chance de
chanter partout en france dans le
maghreb à tahiti enfin voila je me suis
vraiment régalé et après j'ai décidé
d'arrêter pour pour faire d'autres
choses j'ai eu des enfants donc voilà on
aime s'occuper de ma famille j'ai
développé des affaires et aujourd'hui je
rechante pour pour m'amuser ça pourrait
revenir la star ac ou pas je sais qu'il
ya eu un moment et à un moment ça on en
sent sans parler du oui non mais ça
évidemment pas ce que c'est c'est une
émission dont tout le monde fantasme
ouais mais la problématique qu'on a très
clairement et et quand on voit la
qualité de production c'est que c'est
une émission qui demande énormément de
moyens qui est très cher à manches et la
quotidienne et en plus voilà qui vivait
aussi et que l'économie de la
quotidienne je suis pas sûr qu'apple et
sur lesquels les artistes américains
venaient or les artistes américains
voyagent beaucoup moins qu'avant sur le
web et donc ça serait compliqué
maintenant d'avoir un tel plateau donc
si vous me demandez je trouve ça
difficile maintenant elle peut revenir
d'une autre manière peut-être il était
payé les artistes américains pour venir
où ils étaient autant une question alors
il y en a certains oui il y en a
certains qui étaient payés alors payer
ça veut dire on prend le jet
d'anciens étriquée que celle entre les
frac l'hôtel et
après en a d'autres qui était en promo
et dans ces cas-là ils n'étaient pas
payés mais les français aussi été payés
souvent il ya le bien sûr les pros cette
faille mais c'est normal
et et c'est vrai qu'il y avait alors il
ya un truc c'était le système
d'illumination chaque semaine et trois
élèves ayant obtenu la moins bonne note
des évaluations étaient nominés et
soumis au vote du public à l'issue du
prime l'élève qui avait récolté le plus
de votes de la part des téléspectateurs
était sauvée et au niveau des votes on a
toujours dit voilà qui avait peut-être
des gens n'étaient plus l'avantagé que
les autres est ce que c'est vrai
alors
vous savez quoi j'étais moi sur la scène
je ne sais pas ce qu'ils faisaient en
coulisse d'accord non mais c'est tout ça
c'est aussi du fantasme voilà c'est ça
est ce qu'il n'ya pas de mystère ce
qu'ils ont gagné c'est ce qu'a vers un
vrai talent qui ont touché le public est
d'ailleurs ils ont eu des carrières
après donc à un moment
tu sais pas quoi vous dire non c'est pas
devoir est pas parce que ce que veut
dire plein de gens qui disent oui ils
arrêtaient les votes quand il voulait
non c'était ça c'était sur le losc
conserve un seul faux c'est arrivé c'est
quand il voulait pas du tout ils ont été
les bottes à 9 heures 9h10 pour sauver
de mémoire de mémoire la laf la forêt
c'est la seule fois où ils ont fait ça
comptait 1000 fois donc c'est voilà
j'étais une des candidates est a fait du
deuxième but deuxième numéro
effectivement ils ont mis un disque il
ya trop d'appels et ne vous rappelez il
est beau tout est clôturée et depuis cet
épisode là en fait le lycée maintenant
contrôlé l'ouverture des bottes et la
mesure la seule chose qui est vraie dans
l'est dans les trucs de votre nom comme
ça c'est qu'on savait très bien en
production qui avait plutôt le vent en
poupe et qu'à chaque fois que des gens à
météo en avant il y avait un tel écart
de 2 de vote qu'on savait très bien que
si on mettait un candidat face à un
autre il n'y avait aucune chance que ça
s'est passé pas de la triche pas sur une
balle arrêtée c'est d'arrêter de vote
d'accor alors l'une des candidates qui a
marqué fatiha lequel plus marquée la
star ac 6 et l'hiver vous en avait parlé
d'un instant qu a fait une carrière
incroyable derrière ça c'est ça c'est
une fierté c'est une énorme fierté
puisque c'est très touchant qu'elle soit
elle mais maintenant je rêve ouais donc
donc c'est une super histoire et
d'ailleurs c'était hyper mignon parce
que alors pour tes seins dont ils vont
fêter l'anniversaire et on était tous
réunis dont ben magali mario on était
sur la même émission et
jenny elle a pleuré elle a pleuré elle a
pleuré l'idée de revivre ce moment
d'émotion ce qui était toute petite à
l'aide de 19 ans mais ça lui fait monter
les larmes et elle a été submergée par
l'émotion et je trouve ça hyper touchant
regardez
84 jours d'efforts de joie
et ce soir là de vous deux a été choisi
par le public les résultats du public
je vous hais cette voie denis remporter
[Musique]
la première
l'académie
allez on sera pas plus à tout à quel
point c'était un phénomène c'est vrai
faire parce que nous le lendemain comme
je présente exclusif on l'avait c'était
l'interview exclusive de la gagnante
c'était un truc de dingue et on la farce
et des glaces et matthieu delormeau à la
présentation
à la présentation d'autres stars
actuelles ont montré de oui c'était pas
2 millions si je vais vous montrer bah
vous avez fait des bons scores aussi
selon nguyên bergelt à 1,2 mais
vous savez que je laisse cette interview
2 de jennifer regardez nous l'avions
premier samedi soir lors de la finale de
l'émission star academy va nous avons ce
soir avec nous la grande gagnante de
cette incroyable aventure et jennifer 19
ans qui a remporté 60 % des suffrages
des très beaux jennifer pourquoi le vote
du public à pencher pour vous qu'est-ce
que vous avez plus que les autres
candidats eh bien je ne sais pas elle
demande au public non c'est pas ça je
pense les universités c'est par rapport
différents goûts musicaux puisse être
que je suis plus malléable que les
autres peut-être que c'est autre chose
on ne sait pas
mais à l'époque
quoi que fasse jennifer ça se vendait
c'est à dire que l est et en partenariat
l'émission avec un célèbre coiffeur et
notamment il lui mettait des barrettes
et le lendemain de chaque prime c'était
rupture deux adoptent des fameuses
départ est dans le dans les tous les
salons de coiffure de france et de
navarre a le même problème avec les
bijoutiers chez avec
marianne servi un port de fraîcheur
laquelle amène alors je vous dis y avait
il me rappelle du portrait de jennifer
et on l'a vu la dernière fois alors à
l'époque ça passe très très bien sûr que
maintenant le même portrait parce qu on
s'en prenait plein la gueule regarder
[Musique]
à
18 ans que jennifer a déjà un sacré
tempérament débordante d'énergie et
toujours enjoué cette belle niçoise a
décidé de prendre la vie du bon côté je
vis à cent à l'heure je bouge tout le
temps j'adore la vie je laime jacques
roth à peine dans l'air mais aujourd'hui
jennifer n'a rien perdu de sa souplesse
pour canaliser son trop plein de
vitalité elle se défoulent dans le sport
au programme fitness box et footing ce
qui lui permet aussi de surveiller sa
ligne
c'est pour ça c'est renoncer un pétage
de plombs 90 c
est ça par exemple ça passe et
scandalisée de même réservé leur glas
non non mais c'est bien de dire elle a
résidé surtout quand même pour rappel
c'était moi donc je vais pas laisser
vrai mais ccc c'est vrai que c'est que
là et maintenant porsche ag vingt ans
après comme qu'on avait plus du milliard
en temps ça oui
c'est vrai qu'il faudrait pas refaire
vous éloignez fut mais aussi dehors tout
ça ça serait plus possible ouais oui
alors ça je suis pas sûr que ce soit une
mauvaise chose parce que vraiment il y
avait une liberté si pes qui on l'a pas
indiquée pour dire qu'à 90 et on l'a
indiqué que c'était drôle stephen y
avait plus de légèreté quoi c'était très
léger d'ailleurs les sujets étaient très
léger c'est quoi le souvenir que je
garde la de magali ta victoire ma
victoire mais oui forcément même si
chaque moment afin que ce soit avec les
copains où les artistes avec qui j'ai pu
partager des diots reste marquant
forcément ma victoire c'est ouais c'est
le point culminant mines culminant
pardon de cette aventure et c'est un
truc de fou de la belle conclusion oui
kelly j'aimerais savoir ce que vous avez
fait de l'argent
je
sais pas j'ai pas gérer l'argent comme
j'aurais dû mail à 18 ans j'ai été mal
entouré j'ai fait des mauvais choix
passants et voilà donc aujourd'hui voilà
je vis comme tout le monde
voit le million rien bah oui parce que
ça vu que c'est une avance nette sur les
ventes d'albums oui c'est imposa déjà à
wigan donc il reste quand même 600 700
des 1 650 mille ha non à l'époque
josé gaudet s'est fait en plus c'était à
peu près la moitié des 600 milles web
c'est à peu près la moitié oui mais oui
après voilà j'ai été mal entouré j'ai
fait le mauvais choix j'ai voilà mais ce
qui
est grave et il semble quand même
un mec à l'excès en rigoler mario wii
ouais bon j'ai pas y penser du bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais flambée est franchement vous
incite auriez des jeunes chanteurs à le
faire aujourd'hui si la ville sur l'axé
un truc de ouf si on est passionné ouais
parce qu'il faut quand même y aller
parce que des fois c'est pas facile et
oui il faut être passionné faut aimer ça
vous feriez the voice aujourd'hui c'est
non non non pourquoi maman parce que
d'un gérant porter une émission je pense
corse est d'accord laisser la place aux
autres et ontario non parce que je suis
passé à autre chose vraiment eu je
disais c'est une super aventure humaine
en son sein un peu plein plein plein la
gueule pendant dix ans encore
aujourd'hui les missions qu'on vous
allez voir le 30 elle est juste
exceptionnelle c'est ça on a passé des
moments formidables aller voilà après
aujourd'hui je reçois un album qui
sortira l'année prochaine mais parce que
ma petite fille qui a 10 ans me le
demandent depuis des mois et je le fais
aujourd'hui avec beaucoup de plaisir
parce que j'ai pas besoin de ça pour
vivre d'accord donc du coup on n'est pas
dans le même délire on l'a on se sent
qu'il était bien le marché bien ça
marche pas c'est pas grave tu es bien
dans ta tête tu es bien d'autres encore
et pourtant c'est important mon alex bon
bah écoute j'espère que l'on fera une
autre star ac' moi je pense que c'est
une fois je pense que c'est un test de
tf1 et 20 ans et qu'après peut-être y
aura des princesses est peut-être
arrivée la marque d'ailleurs assez
intelligent de leur part après la
confiance est très loin ce soir là je
les regarde et je suis un petit peu
chafouin away pas évident la concevoir
la concurrence est très dure ce soit là
où tout avait un gros match de rugby
ses chances et les climats au téléfilm
sur france 3 c'est ok base et artistes
néo
s'est luxé le groupe pcas sa célèbre we
made you